MAYBE I LD FOR
AT JOB THEN.
QUITE RDY ANYWAY, SO IT WAS OK
IDLEREPUBLIC
YOU'AR DNOONRIGGED
BELCTION TRUMP.LE IN THE REPUB
WAST
>> MY TUSOW
IT'S THE SAME THING TH I SAID  A
BU EVIDENCE. SORRY.
BALLOTS INTOULTON COUNTY, ORGIA.
NO MATNY
TH H
THD  IN FULTONRO
COUNTED.
SO
ET ODEYING IT. THIS IS THECT BET
AND EVEN WHEN 'S PRESITHITH.RIG?
THEM.DENT WE DON'T AGREE WITH, W
WE ALSO WANT TO BELIEVE THAT
TH K
KNOWSO, IF THENG
STOOD  EAS
E HE
MORNING LECTION INSAS STOL.W, L
EVERY, H
WHICH IT WASN'T --D NO
THE VOTET POINT.
A MOMENT
ST TO REMINDEWERS.BEING THOMENT
>> THIS IS A ON TH
AMERICAN
THIS IS AN E TO OUR
COY.ERY TO
THLEY, WE DID WITH
IT'S A IT'S A VERY
ANASNE WON
>> THAWAS M E WHEDIGLOOK.
HERE ARE
E YOURL RI, THAT'SWHD
COME
BA
TH, THE TEWARI.
TH TUS TD O ME WAS
DISTRACTING AN
DID BAD ON CHILD.
AT CHILD REACTN,YBRENT OUT THERT
CERTAIN ES
WHY?
BECAUSE SOME STATETE
MACHND NDED TO BE F
LIKEHIO,WAS N E BEGINNING.UT THR
LL
COUNTED  OHI, , EI
THFAS.THE FAAR TE IDEN, IN MY
OPINION, BECAUSE HVDEHEY ON HIM.
BUT GUESS
THEY WANTED TO PERFORMANCE.
I'LL TELL YOORON.
MARY PAT A I SAT WITH HINTINE'S
LUNCWIN THE DININGHE SAID TOS
POLITICAL VIE?I MR WIN T
E STSHBL
DOESNTEOK WHEE' SITTING
U' PRESIDENT.
GOG TEIDE. MAKE THE NEXT
MATHT
, D HE LOOD  ME, AND YOU'LL
REMEMBER THIHOOK HIS SAID, HE
ORRY TOO MUCI THI D STGH.
, THERE.NG GOVERR  LAW  WORKING
>> MEST ICANTLINCREASED RIS GOE
ES ON CHA?
>> I WOULD M P AAL TO RESET OURY
TO BRING COMNI TY TO
THEM BETCAUSE WEAK BTOIN
WEAD WITA ONAND BY LARGE
VOLUME OF IT.BUTHD NATUREELLECTS
LD, UNFAIRTRADE DE
THAT TO STOP
'RE NO LONGEIN
THEYGEST ECUP ON US TARIFFS WY,E
OSFFS ALSO INCREASE PRIC GET RIE
BE FAIHIA,AL
N THAT.
OUR SOCIAL MEDIA INTO  LEYSTATI.
THEY NEED TOAT BUT W
SO, I DON'T WANT TO VET N N WNL
I WANT TO USE IT AG
FORWARHT
THIS
REHE